la operación policial inició antes del
amanecer utilizando equipos
antidisturbios gas pimienta y un
helicóptero los organismos de seguridad
de nueva zelanda despejaron las vías
alrededor del parlamento en wellington
desde hace más de tres semanas estaba
instalado allí un campamento de
ciudadanos que se oponen a la exigencia
obligatoria de la vacunación quienes
ante la acción policial decidieron
prender fuego a las tiendas de campaña
la operación es el resultado de una
importante planificación y el compromiso
de varios cientos de empleados de todo
el país nuestra intención era recuperar
las vías públicas y restaurar el orden
estuvo ahora una escena inédita para
este pequeño país de 5 millones de
habitantes poco acostumbrado a este tipo
de manifestaciones ha sido el uso de la
fuerza policial más significativo desde
que iniciaron las protestas -inspiradas
en las que recientemente sacudieron a
canadá la primera ministra de nueva
zelanda calificó las acciones de los
anti vacunas de incomprensibles
en todo nos hemos sentido enojados
durante esta ocupación después de todo
cuando estamos en medio de una pandemia
tenemos 400 personas hospitalizadas y
20.000 enfermas en un solo día es casi
imposible comprender que la gente se
oponga a los esfuerzos por frenar eso y
ayudar a cuidar a los más vulnerables
nueva zelanda es uno de los países que
aplicó las políticas más estrictas del
mundo para intentar contener los
contagios sin embargo ya inició la
flexibilización de las medidas en sus
fronteras a partir del 2 de marzo los
neozelandeses procedentes de australia
totalmente vacunados ya no deben
realizar cuarentena en los centros
gubernamentales para el 5 de marzo
podrán ingresar en cualquier país y a
partir de octubre podrán entrar todos
los extranjeros con visado